The first and
probably the most popular of Kruchten's five views is the logical view.
This conveys the structural breakdown of the computational, communicational, and
behavioral responsibilities of the system.
There's lots of ways of conveying logical views.
Probably the most frequently used is a box and arrow diagram.
We'll see a slide in a second.
You've already encountered some of the UML diagrams
that can be used to convey the logical view, including the class model diagram,
interaction overview, and collaboration diagrams.
And also, we will be seeing the components and
connectors that are part of architectural description languages.
Here's a random box and arrow diagram.
It contains boxes which indicate the, the the functional components of a system,
and arrows connecting them indicating some kind of dependency between the boxes.
Box and arrow diagrams have the benefit of being familiar.
And usually can convey a whole lot about the high-level architecture in terms of
a single slide.
However, they have the disadvantage of being imprecise.
Just what is it that those arrows mean?